well i think this is really about the
university system so there was this sort
of presumption
uh by people on the right that what
happens in the university stays in the
universities and that's not correct
basically
an entire ruling elite class was created
in the universities
to understand why that is you have to
understand what universities have become
it used to be
universities trained you to be a good
citizen and also trained you for a job
and now unless you are what we call the
ucla south campus major right
a stem major they're not training you
for either they're training you to not
be a very good citizen
but they are training you to be a
membership of the ruling class and the
way we can tell you're a member of the
ruling class is you speak the lingo
right this is what colleges have become
there's a reason like what did you learn
in college i was a north campus major
not much i came out with a credential
what does the credential mean the
credential means two things one i'm
smart enough to make through college and
two i've now been trained in speaking
the language of the sophisticates and
this is what you see on twitter when
people put their pronouns in their
profiles for example
it's the reason why people put their
college degrees in their profiles it's
because it is saying i am a member of
the elect
now what they hate more than anything is
if you're a member of the elect but you
don't actually
speak the lingo or you don't like the
lingo that's not okay but
we've created this sort of super-powered
group of people who are going to run the
world and we did it
by sending them to these institutions
where they
rack up massive amounts of debt and
learn what they are supposed to say at
cocktail parties in order that they are
well accepted
in the halls of of liberal
intelligentsia and in the halls of power
and and that's that's a real problem
because the reality i mean is peter
thiel is fond of saying is that
you know college does not educate you
for a job there we'd be much better off
if we had an apprenticeship system in
the united states for most jobs
and college is is basically a place
where you go to get a credential and
blow a couple hundred thousand bucks and
drink
and then we hear like my governor at
least for now
gavin newsom saying this is the
opportunity we've been looking for so in
some ways it's like yeah they did
all want this because now federal
bailouts suddenly california has money
even though money
isn't isn't worth much inflation that's
not a thing anymore right
yeah i mean the the basic idea from the
left has always been that emergency is a
ratchet it's a one-way ratchet and
whether you're talking about the great
depression or world war ii or whether
you're talking about
the so-called war on poverty and
certainly now every crisis is an
opportunity to grow government
and because the left thinks not only in
terms of institutional control but in
terms of doing things right the way that
you measure a good precedence according
to the left
is the president did things now the way
you measure a good president according
to the right is
did they pursue policies that were
effective in helping americans for the
left it doesn't matter
right the most transformative presidents
are the ones who may have lengthened the
great depression by eight years and in
turn hundreds of thousands of japanese
people but they did a lot of stuff
and the same thing with lbj right he was
a terrible president he presided over to
the disastrous vietnam war
he presided over tremendous breakdown in
race relations he
did a couple of things that were
obviously very good the voter right with
the voting rights bill and the and the
civil rights act
but overall not a good president but a
transformational president because he
did a lot of stuff barack obama
much less successful president than bill
clinton bill clinton footnote to history
because he was too moderate
barack obama hugely important because he
passed obamacare and you're seeing the
same thing with biden now this is
biden's mentality with regard to
government action
so i've been thinking something that i'm
going to drop in this interview with ben
shapiro right now since you're bringing
up biden and obama
my suspicion and ben you know i'm going
off the grid in a week
but that the biden mental collapse is so
obvious
at this point that it can't hold much
longer and i think they thought they
were going to get at least a year i'm
not so sure they are
that the way it's going to break the
seal the way it's going to actually get
into mainstream because we can all talk
about it but no one will talk about it
on cnn
etc is that obama in an interview is
going to say something he's going to
have a one-liner saying you know maybe
joe's lost a step or two and then
suddenly everyone's going to start
saying it
what do you think about that i think the
only way that obama does that is if he
thinks that
there's a backup plan the problem for
the democrats no meaning he'll have a
full
backup plan but he'll be the one that is
basically going to take out biden i mean
i think that if that i think
if that does happen if there's a backup
plan you're right that it would be
obama who would do it he's the only
person inside the democratic party who
is well respected enough to get away
with it
uh the problem for the democrats is they
really really need joe biden i mean they
really need a job
because what's waiting in the wings is
kamala harris and man is she unpopular
and man is she bad at this she is
just garbage at this job and her job is
really easy and she's really terrible at
it so
you know i i wouldn't honestly if the
democrats had a way of supplanting
kamala harris with michelle obama i i
think that they would try something like
that
yeah i'm just i just have a feeling it's
gonna be obama that's the one that's the
airlock basically because he's the he's
the one that will just slightly leak it
out and then the plan will be there that
is my
almost august prediction all right
chapter three you sort of hit on some of
this already
the creation of a new ruling class that
that seems to be what this is all about
right now
yeah well i think this is really about
the university system so there was this
sort of presumption
uh by people on the right that what
happens in the university stays in the
universities and that's not correct
basically an entire ruling elite class
was created in the universities
to understand why that is you have to
understand what universities have become
it used to be
universities trained you to be a good
citizen and also trained you for a job
and now unless you are what we call the
ucla south campus major right
a stem major they're not training you
for either they're training you to not
be a very good citizen
but they are training you to be a
membership of the ruling class and the
way we can tell you're a member of the
ruling class is you speak the lingo
right this is what colleges have become
there's a reason like what did you learn
in college
i was a north campus major not much i
came out with a credential what does the
credential mean the credential means two
things one
i'm smart enough to make through college
and two i've now been trained in
speaking the language of the
sophisticates and this is what you see
on twitter when people put their
pronouns in their profiles for example
it's the reason why people put their
college degrees in their profiles it's
because it is saying i am a member of
the elect
now what they hate more than anything is
if you're a member of the elect but you
don't actually
speak the lingo or you don't like the
lingo that's not okay but
we've created this sort of super powered
group of people who are going to run the
world and we did it
by sending them to these institutions
where they
rack up massive amounts of debt and
learn what they are supposed to say at
cocktail parties in order that they are
well accepted
in the halls of liberal intelligentsia
and in the halls of power
and and that's that's a real problem
because the reality i mean is peter
thiel is fond of saying is that
you know college does not educate you
for a job there we'd be much better off
if we had an apprenticeship system in
the united states for most jobs
and college is is basically a place
where you go to get a credential and
blow a couple hundred thousand bucks and
drink
by by the time your kids uh who are all
under 10
by the time they make it to college age
do you think college is going to look
anything remotely like it looks i don't
know i mean i think by the time my kids
are in college
i think that everything is going to be
online i think they're going to be able
to pick and choose what kind of courses
they want to take
and i think frankly that a lot of
businesses will have gotten wise to the
scam that college is and they'll just
start hiring directly out of high school
i think you're going to see people
going back to almost an old model where
they say okay well you got straight a's
in high school you're obviously smart
come here an apprentice for
two three years and and then we'll pay
you
chapter four how science trademark
defeated actual science this was making
me think of that great
fouchy line when he basically said i am
the science he went full palpatine
on us that's basically what's happened
here right you challenge this guy and
you're challenging
science yeah and this is the schtick of
the left is that there are two problems
with regard to science and and
they sort of move toward
authoritarianism one is the idea that
the science is an institution
and not in in actual process right
normally science is a process not an
institution
when you have fauci declaring order 66
uh on everybody who disagrees with them
it's it's obviously indicative of a
broader mindset the two big problems
with that you see
inside the scientific community are one
i label the ultra crepitarian problem
mainly because i love the word ultra
crepit area but it basically has a new
word
speaking outside of your your actual
purview so you see this
from for example during the last
pandemic uh
when people said all of a sudden that
racial justice
was a health issue you said yourself
hold up a second how did you explain
that one how exactly is racial justice a
public health issue
and there's no actual rationale it's
just we're scientists we have a doctrine
in front of our name
therefore respect me when i talk about
race relations so well you don't know
anything about race relations i don't
know what you're talking about right so
scientists speaking outside their
purview but using the imprimatur of
science in order to push it
and this leads in reverse to what i call
the bleed over effect which is where
people will say things that are
unscientific and then pretend
that the actual science supports them
and so you have this
this people who will say things that are
just political but then they will say
that
this is the science right so that's what
fauci was doing is he was saying
you know not he was saying here is a
political perspective
on what the what the rates of herd
immunity are
but politics is defining that but i'm
now going to say that that's science
and that opens the door to all sorts of
bad things being treated as science
even though they're not actually
scientific and so it's it's a really
high level form of gaslighting
specifically because we all do
science is like the last institution
that we actually respect because it's
verifiable
so if you remove the verifiability of
science and instead you make it into an
institution you guaranteed yourself an
enormous amount of power but only by
undermining
what science was supposed to be in the
first place well they love science
except if you ask them how many genders
there are yeah exactly
and then it gets a little bit confusing
or whether a baby in the womb is a baby
like a minute before it's born
right exactly even though as you know
we're we're in the middle of surrogacy
right now and basically
a day after or two days after they put
the egg in the sperm together
we know the sex and it's like the
doctors you don't you don't
it's not a click down menu with you know
47 options uh
this isn't specifically what's in the
book but when i was reading this chapter
on science i was thinking that it's a
little bit sort of like your last book
which that this we're worshiping science
now perhaps instead of worshiping god or
having some
set of beliefs outside of ourselves does
that just seem like the obvious
conclusion of a
of a purely secular society yeah we'll
just worship things that will change
every day
yeah i mean i think that's right i think
that human beings have a religious
impulse and somebody's something's gonna
fill that religious impulsion why not
the thing that has brought us
unbelievable prosperity high levels of
technological advancement
it's prevented up to this point disease
and death in extraordinary numbers
right why wouldn't you worship that
thing the problem is it's not a thing
it's a process
so you can certainly have respect for
the process but there have to be some
guiding values beyond just the process
the problem is that people don't have a
habit of following the
the system they're more interested in
just appointing people as their great
leaders
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell